what I found personally fascinating in
Bhutan is this importance of tradition
of keeping the traditions and at the
same time is a very fast move into
modernization and technology lot of
people have moved directly from
manuscript to computer without going
through the pen and the typewriter which
is quite amazing and you so this is
really fascinating and the social media
is huge in Buda on a population of
750,000 we have hundred thousand people
on Facebook and ten thousand people on
Twitter including all the politicians so
it is it is you it is used and maybe not
expected in the conventional sense of
the conventional wisdom about boota
boota has done great great progress in
health education because it's free in
Bhutan for everybody including the
migrants like me originally so this is
great but it is facing a lot of
challenges one of the challenges is of
course to have the revenue money coming
in depending less on foreign aid and
less on India and more on its personal
revenue from idle hydroelectric project
so that's what second biggest challenge
is a success of education it might be
very contradictory to say that but
because education was such a success we
have hundreds fifty thousand kids in the
schools basically everybody goes to
school young kids when they finish their
secondary high school or colleges don't
want to do any blue collar job so we
have to in Bhutan
we have to import import a lot of
migrant workers from India basically
do all the blue-collar job and we have
an employment rate which is about four
percent because there is mismatch
between the aspiration of the young
people educated people and the jobs not
everybody can be an sitting in an office
with a computer and that's what
everybody aspires to so there has been a
shift in the past five years regarding
the blue-collar jobs the dignity of
Labor vocational training and so on but
it is changing slightly but it is also
very difficult because of parents have
tough time to understand that somebody
who has gone to college has to take a
blue-collar job very very difficult for
the parents to accept it so there is a
mismatch and education there is a big
big rethinking now about the education
priorities at the same time it is the
success of education of course ok so
that's one big challenge is that the
youth unemployment another big challenge
is the rural urban migration and that's
why the government is trying to
emphasize on development of Technology
in the rural area and have community
'center so that the rural people can
have sex to computer to social media
they go to a center and an e governance
ego balance is also very important in
Bhutan a lot of things can be done on
internet you feel your form and you get
it that is including working the work
permit it's done online so a lot of
things are done online but they really
want to move into a governance
completely which according to me will
not be feasible before 10 years or 15
years because of the infrastructure
necessary for the cable and all this but
it is quite quite quite amazing so the
is to keep also people in the rural area
so that they don't say oh we are left
behind by the government and this is to
prevent one of the reasons to prevent
rural-urban migration and another
problem in route in urban areas the drug
abuse of course compared to Bangkok of
Manila even the u.s. or Canada maybe
there is not much many drug addicts but
for Boonton which is a small society we
all know each other as there is a saying
in bhutan saying either you are related
by blood or your relative by marriage
and sometime both you know so everybody
knows everybody and when of and drug
abuse touches all the society all the
layers of the society from the richest
to the poorest and the tribes abused are
mostly with medicine sniffing glue and a
little bit of cannabis but I believe
cannabis is going to be local legalized
in the US so I don't know if it's a drug
or not tobacco is from a pound and
they're very close and now they are
attacking head-on alcoholism which is a
huge problem in Bhutan it's like in
France it's cultural way of dealing of
living you you drink but the way the
drinking buta is considered now as a
drug abuse so the government and the
social of the societies because we have
a lot of social societies have to deal
with this problem this is one of the
biggest problem input